all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that energy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
don't do
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
okay
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
what
[Music]
princess
this
or
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states accompanied by justice
clarence thomas and justice amy coney
[Applause]
barrett
[Music]
oh thank you very much
appreciate it thank you very much
distinguished guests and my fellow
citizens
this is a momentous day for america
for the united states constitution and
for
the fair and impartial rule of law
the constitution is the ultimate
defense of american liberty the faithful
application of the law is the
cornerstone of our republic that is why
as president
court justices on this october evening
and it is so beautiful the first lady
and i welcome you to the white house to
bear witness to
history in a few moments we will
proudly swear in the newest member of
the united states supreme court
justice amy coney barrett
she is one of our nation's most
brilliant legal scholars
and she will make an outstanding justice
on the highest court in our land just
as barrett's oath will be administered
by the court's longest serving member
currently on the bench a man whose
allegiance to the law has earned him the
respect
and gratitude of all americans justice
clarence thomas
[Applause]
our country owes a great debt of thanks
to
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
we appreciate it very much mitch thank
you
[Applause]
and we are grateful as well to the
senate judiciary chairman lindsey graham
thank you lindsay
[Applause]
also with us senators marsha blackburn
mike braun bill cassidy kevin cramer
ted cruz steve james
ron johnson james lankford
mike lee and martha mcsally
and i hope i didn't leave anybody out
and a very special thanks to our great
vice president
mike pence thank you mike
also i want to thank white house counsel
pat cipolloni thank you pat
and very importantly i want to welcome
justice barrett's husband
jesse thank you jesse
thank you
let me also recognize your seven
children your great beautiful children
who have
become really uh just uh very very
popular in this nation
people have been watching them and
loving them and they're watching right
now back home in
indiana thank you very much
but i speak to everyone when i say that
the barrett family has captured
america's heart it is highly fitting
that justice barrett
fills the seat of a true pioneer for
women
it's justice ruth bader ginsburg
tonight justice barrett becomes not only
the
fifth women to serve on our nation's
highest court
but the very first mother of school-aged
children to become a supreme court
justice very important
over the past few weeks the entire world
has seen
justice barrett's deep knowledge
tremendous poise and towering intellect
she answered questions for hours on end
throughout her entire confirmation her
impeccable credentials were unquestioned
unchallenged and obvious to all
justice barrett earned a full academic
scholarship
to notre dame law school
graduated first in her class and served
as a clerk
for justice antonin scalia
she was a beloved professor at
notre dame law school for 15 years
before
i very proudly appointed her to the u.s
circuit court of appeals for the seventh
circuit in 2017.
the american people have been profoundly
impressed to learn of her achievements
her
compassion her generosity her faith and
her
sterling character justice
barrett made clear she will issue
rulings based solely upon
a faithful reading of the law and the
constitution as written
not legislate from the bench
the equal impartial and constitutional
rule of law that we enjoy
every day in america is one of the
crowning achievements in the history of
human civilization
it is the triumph of reason experience
and the values which are eternal and
everlasting
our devotion to this inheritance is what
has made america the most just
exceptional and glorious nation ever
to exist i want every american child
watching to understand that this is a
very special
and important ceremony we are fulfilling
the duty that passes to each new
generation to sustain
the national traditions and virtues that
make possible
everything we have achieved before that
we will do tomorrow because of our
constitution and our culture of freedom
you live in a land where anything is
possible
and where any dream can come true
no matter who you are no matter your
background
in america everyone is entitled to equal
protection
under our laws and your sacred rights
can never
ever be taken away
the march of liberty that began with the
american revolution
continues onward this evening
tonight at the white house we carry
forward the cause of freedom
equality and justice for which so many
generations of americans have given
so much we honor the cause for which men
died
to win the civil war and for which they
jumped out of
airplanes and shed their blood on
distant
battlefields we honor the immortal
principles inspired millions in the
struggle for civil rights
and we take special pride in the nation
that
inspires billions of people all over the
world
we must never take this radiant
inheritance
for granted we must never lose
confidence
in our history our heritage
or in our heroes
to reach for the stars we must stand
upon the strong and sturdy foundation
built by those incredible americans who
came before
just as barrett as you take your oath
tonight
the legacy of our ancestors falls to you
the american people put their trust in
you
and their faith in you as you take up
the task
of defending our laws our constitution
and this country that we all love
we ask god to give you wisdom and
courage
i know you will make us all very
very proud as long as we are loyal
to our founding and to our fellow
citizens
america's future will be bright
america's destiny will be great
and america's people will forever
and always be free
i now ask justice thomas to administer
the oath thank you very much
hi amy tony barrett is solemnly swearing
that i will support and defend the
constitution
of the united states that i will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
against all enemies foreign and domestic
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the saints
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
that i take this obligation freely that
i take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation without
any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion or purpose of
evasion
and that i will well and faithfully
discharge
and that i will well and faithfully
discharge
the duties of the office from which i am
about to end
the duties of the office on which i am
about to enter
so help me god so happy god
thank you thank you so very much
thank you all for being here tonight and
thank you president trump
for selecting me to serve as an
associate justice of the united states
supreme court
it's a privilege to be asked to serve my
country
in this office and i stand here tonight
truly honored and humbled
thanks also to the senate for giving its
consent
to my appointment i am grateful for the
confidence you have expressed in me
and i pledge to you and to the american
people
that i will discharge my duties to the
very best
of my ability this was a rigorous
confirmation process
and i thank all of you especially leader
mcconnell and chairman graham
for helping me to navigate it
my heartfelt thanks go to the members of
the white house staff
and department of justice who worked
tirelessly to support me
through this process your stamina is
remarkable
and i have been the beneficiary of it
jesse and i are also so grateful to the
many people
have supported who have supported our
family
over these last several weeks
through ways both tangible and
intangible
you have made this day possible jesse
and i have been truly awestruck
by your generosity
i have spent a good amount of time over
the last month at the senate
both in meetings with individual
senators
and in days of hearings before the
senate judiciary committee
the confirmation process has made ever
clearer to me one of the fundamental
differences
between the federal judiciary and the
united states senate
and perhaps the most acute is the role
of policy preferences
it is the job of a senator to pursue her
policy preferences
in fact it would be a dereliction of
duty
for her to put policy goals aside
by contrast it is the job of a
judge to resist her policy preferences
it would be a dereliction of duty for
her to give in to them
federal judges don't stand for election
thus they have no basis for claiming
that their preferences reflect those of
the people
this separation of duty from political
preference
is what makes the judiciary distinct
among the three branches of government
a judge declares independence
not only from congress and the president
but also from the private beliefs that
might
otherwise move her the judicial oath
captures the essence of the judicial
duty
the rule of law must always control
my fellow americans even though we
judges don't face elections
we still work for you it is your
constitution
that establishes the rule of law and the
judicial independence
that is so central to it
the oath that i have solemnly taken
tonight
means at its core that i will do my
job without any fear or favor
and that i will do so independently
of both the political branches and of my
own preferences
i love the constitution and the
democratic republic that it establishes
and i will devote myself to preserving
it
thank you
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
[Music]
good work
oh
[Music]
thank you
oh
i killed myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
okay